Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
İnsan hayatının, insanın kendisini
böyle kaygılı ve huzursuz
hissetmesinin temelinde
aslında belirsizlik vardır.
Belirsizlik hissettiğimiz
zamanlarda neler yaparız?
Böyle, kendimizi, o belirsizliği
daha belirli hâle getirebilmek için
çabalamaya başlarız.
Kimimiz geçmişe doğru
gitmeye çalışırız
ve geçmişten güzel anıları toplayıp
kendimizi iyi hissetmek için
bir şeyler yaparız.
Kimimiz de geleceğe doğru uzanırız
ve geleceğin verilerini bugüne getirerek;
bugünden yarını nasıl inşa edebiliriz
ona bakmaya çalışırız.
Benim işim:
şirketlerin, kurumların
uyumda kalabilmesi için,
kurumlar, çalışanlar ve toplum
arasındaki bağın,
nasıl olması gerektiğiyle ilgili
iletişim temelli çalışmalar yapmak.
"Oyunda kalmak ne demektir?"
diye soracak olursanız;
geçtiğimiz 15 yıl içerisinde,
Fortune 500 şirketlerinin
%52'si uyumda kalamadı
ve yok oldu.
%52...
Uluslararası bir şirket
geçtiğimiz senelerde bir araştırma yaptı
ve bu araştırmada topluma,
sizlere, global bir araştırmaydı,
şöyle bir soru sordu.
Üç soru, birincisi:
Bu marka yaşam kalitenizi artırıyor mu?
İkincisi:
Bu marka toplumun
yaşam kalitesini artırıyor mu?
Üçüncüsü:
Bu marka yok olsa
umrunuzda olur muydu?
Tüm markaların %73'ü yok olsa,
hiçbirimizin umurunda değil!
%73'ü...
Şimdi hepimiz aynı zamanda
o kadar yoğunuz,
o kadar yorgunuz,
o kadar çok çalışıyoruz ki
hiçbir şeye vaktimiz yok.
Ama toplum size gelip diyor ki:
"Yok olsanız umrumda bile değilsiniz!"
Öyleyse bir yerlerde
bir şeyler değişiyor, bir şeyler farklı,
bir şeylerde değişiklik var,
değişim var;
ama nedense o değişim sanki
bizlere henüz yansımamış durumda.
Değişim neden var?
Neden değişiyor iş dünyası?
Hayat, yaşam alışkanlıklarımız.
Değişim var çünkü
kültürlerimiz değişiyor.
Kültürlerimiz değiştiğinde
bizi biz yapan değerler de değişiyor.
Bizi biz yapan değerler değiştiğinde
hayata verdiğimiz anlam da değişiyor.
Hayata verdiğimiz anlam değiştiğinde,
işimizden, eşimizden, arkadaşlarımızdan,
şirketlerden ve markalardan
beklentilerimiz de değişyor.
Peki öyleyse kültürlerimiz
neden değişiyor?
Kültürlerimiz de değiştiren
belli bazı dinamikler var.
Gelin şimdi hep birlikte
bu dinamiklere bakalım.
Bunlardan birincisi: nüfus artışı.
2030 yılına geldiğimizde
Dünya nüfusu 8,5 milyara;
Türkiye'nin nüfusu da 100 milyona çıkıyor.
Bununla birlikte gelişen, büyüyen bir
orta sınıf oluşuyor,
gelir seviyemiz artıyor;
aynı zamanda şehirleşme de yükseliyor.
2030 yılında Dünya nüfusunun %50'si
şehirlerde yaşıyor olacak,
2050'ye geldiğimizde %60'ı,
2100 yılına geldiğimizde
10 milyar kişi, %80'i,
şehirlerde yaşayacak.
Bugünkü Dünya nüfusundan çok daha yüksek
bir rakamdan bahsediyoruz.
Aynı zamanda biliyoruz ki,
bugün çevresel sorunların
en temelinde popülasyon;
yani nüfus artışı yatıyor.
Dolayısıyla önümüzdeki dönemlerde
bu kaynakların dağılımıyla ilgili
sorunların da ortaya çıkacağını
ve bu yüzden de
çevre duyarlılığı yüksek
insanların ve liderlerin bizlerin arasında
olacağını varsayabiliriz.
Bir diğer dinamik: sosyal adalet arayışı.
Amerikan Politikalar Enstitüsü'nün
yapmış olduğu
bir araştırmaya göre
1978 ile 2014 yılları arasında
CEO maaşları %1000 oranında
artış göstermiş.
Bu rapora göre CEO maaşları
ortalama 16 milyon dolar,
çalışan maaşları 56 bin dolar.
CEO maaşları artıyor ama aynı zamanda
çıktılarda çok da fazla
bir gelişme görülmemiş.
Onun haricindeki herkesin
payında bir azalma var.
İşte bu ve bunun gibi sistemdeki
adaletsizliklere karşı
önümüzdeki dönemlerde;
bireylerin, toplumların
çok da sessiz kalacağını varsayamayız.
Çünkü örneklerini de gördük.
Öyle değil mi?
Ortadoğu'da olan olaylar,
Occupy akımları...
Küçücük bir kıvılcımın
teknoloji de kullanılarak,
nasıl bir salgın haline geldiğini
hep birlikte izledik.
Bununla birlikte bankalar battı,
Wikileaks olayları oldu.
Bir dolu olay oldu ve
şu anda günümüzde
kurumlara olan güven düşmüş durumda.
Şuan sadece 4 kurumdan
1 tanesine güveniyoruz.
2008 yılından bu yana %50'lik bir
düşüşe tekabül ediyor.
İlginç bir veri.
Bir diğer dinamik:
katılımcı ve paylaşımcı anlayışlarla
yükselen iş modellerinin
karşımıza çıkması.
Katılımcı ve paylaşımcı...
Bu ne demek?
Oxford Üniversitesi'nin yapmış
olduğu bir araştırma var.
Bu araştırmaya göre
önümüzdeki dönemlerde
41 ülke daha fakirlik seviyesinden
orta sınıf seviyesine çıkıyor.
Yani bir grup toplum tüketimi
teşvik etmeye devam edecek.
Ama daha olgun piyasalarda
"collaborative consumption" dediğimiz,
shared economy dediğimiz
akımlar ortaya çıktı.
Türkçesi pek de bilinmiyor.
Ama ben buna
imece usulü yaşam diyorum
ya da diğer bir deyişle;
katılımcı, paylaşımcı anlayışla
ortaya çıkan yaşam stilleri.
Örneklerle anlatmak istiyorum.
Örneğin otel sektöründen, Airbnb.
Dünya'nın dört bir yanından insan,
tanımadığı insanların evinde kalabiliyor,
otelleri tercih etmiyor.
Kültürel bir etkileşim
sağlamayı tercih ediyor.
Ulaşım sektöründen bir örnek verelim.
Şuanda dünyanın en büyük
araba kiralama şirketlerinin başında
Zipcar geliyor.
Zipcar ne yapıyor?
Zipcar 1 günün içerisinde tek bir aracın
birden fazla kişi tarafından
kullanılmasına olanak sağlıyor.
Hem daha ekonomik
aynı zamanda şehrin içerisindeki
arabaların sayısının da azalmasını,
karbon salınımının da düşmesini sağlıyor.
Geçtiğimiz yıllar içerisinde
geleneksel bir araba kiralama şirketi olan
Avis'e 500 milyon dolara satıldı.
İlginç.
Aynı sektörden Uber'i verebiliriz.
2007 yılında kurulmasına rağmen,
şöyle bir 10 yıllık geçmişi var.
Bugün Dünya'nın en büyük
150 şirketi arasında yer alıyor.
Bu örnekleri daha da çoğaltabiliriz.
Örneğin eBay gibi, Atsee gibi, Letgo gibi
ya da eğitim alanında Coursera gibi,
Edix gibi şirketleri
örnek olarak verebiliriz.
Şimdi bu katılımcı ve paylaşımcı
anlayışla ortaya çıkan şirketler
ve modeller bize bir şeyi gösteriyor:
Güvenin ve gücün yer değiştirdiğini!
Bakın bugün kurumlara olan
güven dip yapmışken,
insanların birbirine olan güveni
yükselerek yaygınlaşıyor.
Güç, merkezi sistemlerden daha dağınık
ve bağımsız sistemlere doğru
ilerlemeye başlıyor.
Bir diğer dinamik:
teknoloji alanındaki gelişmeler.
Özellikle de robotlar ve
öğrenen makineler.
Bundan 1 ay önce Japonya'da bir firma
35 tane çalışanını
bir tek robotla değiştirdi.
Yapay zekaya sahip bir robottu bu.
Verimlilik artışının
%30 olması bekleniyor.
2018 yılına kadar 3 milyon çalışanın,
robotlar tarafından
süpervize edilmesi bekleniyor.
Kanımca işin en ilginç tarafı
insanlar olarak bizler,
bizleri yönetenlerin
insan değil robotlar olmasını
tercih ediyoruz.
Kaliforniya'da Univercity of California
Irivine'da
sanal robot terapistler ortaya çıktı
ve yapılan ilk pilot araştırmalarda
insanların terapiye
psikologlara gitmek yerine,
robot psikologlara
gittiklerinde kendilerini
daha rahat hissettiklerini söylediler.
Tabi robotlar sadece
bilgiyi öğrenmiyorlar.
Onun dışında öğrendikleri
başka bir şey daha var.
O da: duygularımız.
Duyguları dahi öğrenebilen
makineler yapıyoruz.
Ve bu makineleri,
insandan ayırt edebilmemiz,
çok yakın bir gelecekte mümkün olmayacak.
Hanson Robotics'e göre,
önümüzdeki 20 yıl içerisinde
bu robotlar hayatımızın önemli bir
parçası haline gelecek.
Duyguları öğrenen ve
mimikleyebilen robotlar.
Bunun dışında 2007 yılında
IBM Watson isimli
bir robotu ortaya çıkarttı.
Bu robot bugün, 10 yıl içerisinde,
%99.9 başarı oranı ile
ilk seferde onkoloji alanındaki
hastalıkların teşhisini
doğru olarak koyabiliyor.
Öyleyse önümüzdeki dönem içerisinde
rutin işlerin birçoğunun
robotlara geçeceğini;
yaratıcılık, araştırma, geliştirme
ve üst düzey yönetsel yetkinliklerin
arandığı bir dünyaya doğru
geçeceğimizi varsayabiliriz.
Bir diğer dinamik sağlıklı
ve uzun ömür arayışı.
Bugün aranızda
20'li yaşlarında gençler varsa
100 yılın ötesinde
yaşayacağınızı söyleyebiliriz.
Başınıza başka bir şey gelmezse.
2050 yılında her 4 kişiden 1 tanesi,
65 yaş ve üzeri olacak.
Bunun şöyle bir önemi var
işletmeler açısından;
günümüzde genelde şirketler
gençlik pazarına yönelirler.
Önümüzdeki dönemlerden itibaren
orta yaş ve üzeri şirketler için
çok önemli bir pazar haline gelecek.
Ancak bununla birlikte uzun hayat
olunca, mutluluk arayışımız
ve sağlıklı yaşam arayışımız da
yükselmeye başladı.
O yüzden örneğin hastaneler,
önümüzdeki dönemlerde
hastaların, hasta oldukları için
gittikleri merkezler olmaktan çıkıp,
yaşam kalitenizi arttırmak için
çabalayan merkezler,
yaşam merkezleri haline geliyor olacak.
Tüm bunların aslında,
bu savaşların olması,
hayatımızdaki zorlukların olması,
uzun ömrün olması
ve mutlu bir hayat sürme
çabamızın arkasında
aslında bizlerin daha iyi yaşamasını
sağlayan bir bilim var.
Buna da "pozitif psikoloji" diyoruz.
Pozitif psikoloji insanları,
kurumları ve toplumu
daha mutlu, daha umutlu
ve daha tatminkâr
bir yaşamın nasıl elde edileceği
konusunda düşünmeye iteliyor.
Yaşam kalitemizi nelerin,
nasıl artıracağını anlamaya çalışıyor.
Bu yüzden de son 20 yıldır aslında
mutluluk üzerine çalışmalar
bir artış gösterdi
ve anlam arayışımız da
oldukça kuvvetlendi.
Bir diğer dinamik:
sürdürülebilirlik alanındaki gelişmeler.
Önümüzdeki dönemde,
karar mekanizmalarımızın
içerisine sürdürülebilirlik
indeksi giriyor.
Yani bir ürünün üretim noktasından
süpermarkete kadar geçtiği
süreç içerisinde doğaya ve insana
ne kadar saygılı olduğunu
ölçtüğümüz bir indeks geliyor.
Dolayısıyla bir ürünü alırken, sadece
rengine ve şekline bakmıyorsunuz;
aynı zamanda indeks puanına da
bakıyor olacaksınız.
Tüm sürdürülebilirlik
çalışmalarının temeline de
yaşam kalitesini koymak
zorunda kalacağız.
Yani bu ürünler, bu şirketler,
bizlerin ve doğanın yaşam kalitesini
hangi derecede ve nasıl artırıyor?
Son olarak korku ve kaostan
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Almanya, Soğuk Savaş'tan bu yana
ilk defa vatandaşlarından
su ve gıda stoğu yapmasını istedi.
Fransa; 2. Dünya Savaşı'ndan bu yana
ilk defa olağanüstü hal ilan etti.
Amerika Trump'ı seçti.
Türkiye ve Orta Doğu'da
olanlar zaten malumunuz.
Dünya, farklı bir yöne doğru gidiyor.
Sorun artık sadece
Orta Doğu'nun sorunu değil.
Kanımca böyle bir
dünya düzeni içerisinde
hepimizin üzerine düşen
en önemli ve öncelikli görev,
toplumlara güveni yeniden
nasıl inşa edeceğimizdir.
Kanımca geleceğe dair
bu veriler karşısında,
hayatı yavaşlatmanın pek de
mümkün olduğunu
ben şahsen düşünemiyorum.
Ancak inandığım ve olması
gereken bir şey var ki o da;
zihin dinginliğimiz.
Zihnimizi dinginleştirmek zorundayız
ki böylece derin düşünebilelim
ve daha doğru mukakeme
yeteneğimizi güçlendirebilelim.
Bunun için de kendimize ait
zamana ihtiyacımız var.
Kendimizle kalabileceğimiz,
düşünebileceğimiz;
sessiz ve kendimizle
iletişim hâlinde olacağımız zamanlara...
İşte ancak o zaman inanıyorum ki,
gelecek için neler hayal ediyorsak,
o hayatı yaratabilmek için
gereken iradeye kavuşabilir
ve cesaretli adımlarla
istediğimiz yaşamı inşa edebiliriz.
(Alkışlar)
Teşekkürler.